it wasn't just delicious football-shaped
cakes which were cheering Germany coach
um love on the first official day of
preparation for Euro 2016 his
injury-plagued captain was about to
deliver some important news I've been
able to do lots of running in training
in the last few weeks it's looking good
but of course we must remember I have
not played a match since the end of
March but I think my fitness can catch
up with the others quite quickly in our
training sessions all for the very first
training session in a row Germany hope
will lead to the Euro final in Paris on
July 10 had some notable absent T's mats
Hummels is carrying a slight knock and
only 16 of the 27 man squad were put
through their paces with others resting
weary limbs from a tiring domestic
season our main task will be to train
the fit and the lasted so that next week
they can all be at the same level as me
worshipping the world champions are
taking the first steps in their bid to
add the European crown as well